this time we're actually gonna really
focus on surfer oh did I spawn in you
what are you doing you're flying why am
i flying hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to be
separate with ways AI Wade hey guys it's
almost like I just said hi like just two
seconds goes really strong feeling a
deja vu okay so we got a better grasp on
what we're supposed to do so we're gonna
immediately go for resource collection
and try to get something is semblance of
not dying because dying is our strong
suit we can die with the best of us oh
yeah it takes us like half a day you
should see me playing the forest hide
idle no the games great but it's really
hard I played the game I did a play of
it you did you did a play of it I did a
play of it dude I was going to say but a
play works you did a you play of it foul
lady vagabond how dare you trash thine
forest with my eyes oh it's in thine
mind yeah ow ow ow I don't think that
was Shakespeare I think you need to work
on your Mac Bear yeah pretty sure to be
or not to be dude that's your god this
is a big-ass rock we're gonna get so
much rock from this rock yeah dude of
rock levels are gonna be so big I've
only got two rocks I think we need like
four four uh stone axe a stone axe makes
rock collecting so much faster good
we're gonna get there don't worry little
buddy I'm gonna just get one more piece
and then I'm gonna go collect wood so
that we can get a crafting table right
away you just hammer out the rest of
this rock ironically hitting a rock with
an axe is better than hitting a rock
with a knife why would a knife be good
well it wouldn't be but why would an axe
be good well at least an axe has a lot
of weight to it and the fine point that
you can swing in
instead of thrusting or slicing why is
this not breaking I'm putting it I'm
hitting it as hard as I can
where's it breaking off I don't know are
you getting any more out of it ah bonus
rocks and a four or I want more rocks
than or screw it I'm getting wood mm-hmm
fine I'll fight with this how much rock
did you get oh so much rock you don't
even know I'm its rocket Johnny I got
some I have no weight to my inventory I
have three raw stones do you would try
making a stone ass I will
oh wait I thought you needed for I don't
know how much it is how about you played
this game before
like twice you believe an expert cheese
well I mean you played it at least
you're the kind of blessed player that
actually okay I have like ten hours
logged in on that game so don't even get
and were you an expert until you finally
won dude there are no experts in that
game there's no rules in that game it's
all bull no everyone says that you can
go like oh you go left right left right
left left left right and you'll get
there yeah I've done every combination
the peoples is just a bunch of trolls
that are like don't mess and then he'll
fill stubborn when it doesn't work and I
go yeah I felt pretty freaking dumb
playing that game over and over and over
again
but I beat it and I beat it and I never
have to play it again so that's that's
like you beat it for me i watch you play
a lot you can watch my recorded video of
it right of course the live play of
let's play we should bring let's play to
theater and mix Shakespeare in with it
because we're good at that
Oh thou playthrough how art thee o why
dost thou chooses to be L douche did the
Spanish Shakespeare there you know what
I mean Oh L do show the entire community
while also offending me I don't know hey
I'm gonna I got enough wood I'm gonna
start crafting them into play
I like how we can actually be productive
while insulting each other that really
saves a lot of time that's why work so
well together it is true we just make
it's us insulting each other that drives
us to do better in the game oh it only
takes two stone and four logs to make
the axe well I mean why are you
complaining that means we have extra to
make more why are you up cuz I could
have made it earlier
well I be whatever man just calm down
I'm getting the planks ready
it breaks the stone you already have it
where's a crafting table I didn't okay
well then I can make it right now right
yep I'll make a crafting table you get
done with that all I'll make a grab you
disappeared like a dog okay and
everybody wait I'm so sorry another Rock
to spawn right behind you wait wait wait
please good okay okay
it really did it just like popped up out
of nowhere that's awesome that seems to
happen a lot when you break one rock
another one takes its place that's so
convenient how I know what's the
measurement a crap time a stun but load
a buttload is actually a real unit of
measurement I hope you know that is it
no no I'm dead serious I'm not even
joking about this like a bottle or two
curious where it's recognized like I
think it's just to do with barrels like
um there's something about barrels that
there is a possibility having a buttload
of barrels and it's not really Cameron
Diaz there's something about barrels
yes I'm I know of which you speak you're
totally not weird and wrong but are you
definitely right I'm wrong oh I love
being weird and right yes you're so
weird and right hey it so anyway what do
we do now that axis what's next I'm
trying to say I don't know what to do
next I'm running out of him so our
crafting table we need to build a place
to live and we need to get iron to build
a bowl oh that would be smart all of
those things sound like great ideas
let's do the complete opposite and die
okay okay
set no I'm actually don't want to do
that because our lovely fans out there
would be so mad at us if we did that
they won't they watch us because they
won't be educated on the proper
utilization of gaming skills straight
games well if you would like to watch me
gather some sedimentary rock while
markiplier gathers the Birchwood we will
show you the deworm off' occation of our
progression team form of a case when did
our progress get worms actually I
shouldn't say that our progress died a
long time goings been rotting for a
while so it's Edwards reload time
alright anyway I got next to it and I
have a crafting table so I'm gonna help
breakdown this with this kill you in one
hit whoa
rocks up Palooza it would not kill me in
one hit whoa ting Tong Bing bong ding
dong goes to ring wrong this awesome
dude this is freaking awesome how does
this work I don't know it's logical it's
pretty perfect chunks oh my god let's
see oh god do with my rock all right I
see a rock down the coast okay my dear
why that's a weird place for a rock to
be okay stand under it I will get on top
of it and be able to push it onto your
face alright I'm ready
break it with your rock hard skull wait
what does the green thing do is the
green your food bar um yes but it
doesn't work properly it'll randomly
just refill itself
well yeah you just get it from the air
you photosynthesis your way to nutrition
yes that's pretty cool actually I
wouldn't mind man I mean I don't know
how they intended it for it to work but
it's not currently working that way well
good being in the land of dinos means
whoa hello there will Cod your face wait
a minute
swing your axe swing it swing your eggs
okay just your arms move look can you do
it
Crashdown kresson oh my god they're
friggin turtle man your turf don't swing
that in mind
look at how this dumbness look your
shirt like rips as you swing in the door
I know cuz my bustle there's no huge God
thank you sir prepares itself it's like
my butt my butt repairs my it's been my
submit I don't really understand the
language you're speaking does this get
more out of trees I don't think it gets
more but I think it gets it faster time
to medically I I guess you could swing
it faster but either way we got a lot of
rocks what do we do with it now
um we'll need to make a furnace okay Hey
look there's a first down there can we
just take there's I don't know I don't
see why not
I mean there's a lot of resources yours
not and isn't this like a PvE server so
there isn't any dangerous less being
killed I said that I don't know why does
my axe keep not getting in my hands we
keep trying to find servers with people
on it there's not many with people on
this game isn't popular and I can't see
why actually to the game's credit there
is a lot here but there's not much in
the way of polish in the game
I say polish but it's fun yeah it is
it's not bad at all I mean obviously is
an alpha game so there's dinos you could
die I want to get a gun on kill Dino
wake up get a furnace and get our
unidentified ores identified in the
crafting table we get some iron and
stuff we can craft guns oh you were
hammering that away huh okay
well let's build a coastal house so that
we can have a nice picnic where we can
relish each other's company for days on
end all relish that's like a condiment
it is a condom it's great really it's a
pickle condom get a big ol gun but not
pickles you know you big it would be but
it's not pickled can do
I don't even know how that started god
no that fanart it's gonna be on us what
about our heads make us blow them up
like you know how you put it on you blow
it up with your nose are you on the
coast yeah
chopping a rock down by the coast we're
here for the rocks down by the coach
yeah I've chopped it away it won't be
here by the time you get here on the
coast there's one there's one further
down as we get to our conversation if I
could ever find my goddamn notebook
brilliant ideas like the dildo gun
dildos in it do those at dawn bill knows
at dusk you know I could visit with thee
oh my god for our first full-length
movie build build those dog you know cuz
we are stuck with bored channels you
know you know of course I want Michael
Beaty director just tons of explosions
as dildos hit people exploding dildos I
love it I love it so much
oh maybe I should essentials pack who
will get Freddie Wong on the team I'll
blow this [ __ ] up million views hey you
oh you guys out there bite make fun of
us but that's that get a lot of you got
bit you know it you would see you'd see
that theatres guys if johnny Knoxville
can you have dildos shot into his butt
then we could have dildos explode while
they're being shot into our butts okay
this is going to drugs I know over there
can we kill it that's a bit bad
yeah I'm try I don't want to kill there
no we risk too much don't die please
dear God don't die all right don't die
okay it's time to make our coastal city
I have right here why don't we leave
five logs I tried you wanna make a try
built me to do it do you mean a tribe I
don't know what its tribe is it's like
how we team up Oh Oh rusty tea and go to
manage you can make a tribe name and
then you can invite me oh my god
tribe name the butt dildos but in there
- that's true that cleans it up a bit
thank you I very high quality stuff we
got going in here created a tribe join
my buddy oh you're already a member of a
tribe I am NOT on this server leave your
tribe ok I just invite you to my tribe
Oh join but dildos right now well I'm in
a tribe you don't join but dildos I will
be very upset with you they can join but
dildos - come on join about dildos you
know you want to come over to the dildos
I won't let me leave my tribe
oh you can't join but dildos well no
those buttons I have it highlighted I
don't even know who's on the loose hmm
fine Oh being but don't knows my spell
here I invited you to what I'm already
in a tribe you can't believe not Jesus
I'll leave it I'll delete it even
alright delete it fine there
invite me there you go go to invites and
hit refresh refresh oh there is duck you
could go yeah you dove yeah delete it
everyone in the church
is gonna be so mad you didn't join but
dildos yeah okay anyway so hard whatever
I have a crafting table let's just this
is gonna this over with
I have a crafting table and I have a lot
of or we're gonna start our base right
here do I need to put this on anything I
forget it's going down okay where do I
put it
I can't I put it anywhere I don't know
what's it say it says read that's what
it says fill was we were in but dildos
who would work like but bill though is
that comes out of a dildo dildo I
thought was a it's a part of the banner
above I don't know I don't know why I
need to explain this you you know dick
but yes I mean depends on your put your
ass no no you know dick but you know
dick but yeah I know exactly you know
dick but coming out of his butt that was
but deal though you got it oh no that'd
be there no don't know that BDO if it's
a bud dildo dick but slash but dildo
means there's a but coming out of the
deal though ASA spell okay please don't
kill me wait you look very dangerous
right now
did your turtle stance I'm sorry I'll
stop talking about bud dildos you want
to go back to pickle condoms yes yes
okay why not
family-friendly of course it is
family-friendly pickle condoms for Paul
AIDS okay good nothing good could come
from this nothing good can come from
pickle dill condoms I put a crafting
table down there I'm gonna bake well oh
my god I can make a blueprint for a
Beretta yeah you have to make the gun we
need to get the or where the devil did
you put this down put it did look for my
name look for my name I'm looking you
know what maybe we should
the next episode because I think we've
reached the pinnacle to quality on this
one okay oh yeah hey so anyway I forgot
the audience was even there I'm sorry
for the things that Wade said he's what
just can't be controlled he's totally
off the wall there anyway thank you all
so much for watching thanks Wade for
being here in the next episode we will
get started on actually making progress
yeah